[Musik]
die mitte europas im wandel der zeit
ein land das lange braucht um eins zu
werden
menschen die sich erst im laufe der
jahrhunderte als deutsch verstehen
[Musik]
wer sind wir
woher kommen wir
[Musik]
fragen an die geschichte der deutschen
die bonus
d
für die republik
[Musik]
unversöhnlich stehen sie sich gegenüber
der könig und der rebell noch gibt es
keine deutschen
aber franken und sachsen
als sich widukind der sächsische
aufrührer endlich taufen lässt ist der
fränkische könig karl seinem großen ziel
näher gekommen
einem christlichen kaiserreich
[Musik]
ein heiliger ort irgendwo in den
sächsischen wäldern ein heiliger ort der
alten germanischen religion die in suhl
ist für die heidnischen sachsen die
säule die den himmel und die erde
verbindet die götter mit den menschen
große den ring
es ist der ort an dem die sächsischen
priester verbindung aufnehmen zu wollen
mona sax not die priester kennen die
uralten zaubersprüche um menschen und
tiere zu heilen
[Musik]
und wenn die götter ist wollen gelingt
die heilung
[Musik]
an einem sommertag des jahres 772 wird
diese alte germanische welt gedroht
nach diesem tag wird nichts mehr so sein
wie es war
auch im leben des sächsischen adeligen
widukind auf neue hochdeutsch wald kind
und seines freundes anno
ruhig das in verruf
[Musik]
es ist ein junger fränkisch natürlich
der mit einer großen schar von reiter
kriegern ein feld in das sachsen markt
[Musik]
wann begreifen was da auf die kinder
hatte noch
[Musik]
die sachsen sind von dem angriff
vollkommen überrascht und velos
jetzt
nein
ist es nur ein überfall ein
eroberungszug wie viele andere
der fränkische könig karl führt seiner
truppen selbst
[Applaus]
die franken sind christen
und für sie sind die sachsen nichts als
ungläubige götzendiener
barbarisch heiden
bleibt sie zusammen
karl der 24 jährige könig der franken
ist sich seiner sache sicher er will
sein reich vergrößern
und auf den heiden christen man sei es
mit feuer und schwert
[Applaus]
an diesem tag tragen die fränkischen
krieger in viele sechs fischerdörfer
zerstörung und tod
es ist eine epoche voller eroberungs mut
und der gewissheit für den eigenen
glauben töten zu dürfen
aus der ohnmacht erwächst hat der
sächsische adelige widukind schwört
rache
das wären sie wissen sperrig
wir werden es ihnen heimzahlen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kann der junge frankenkönig will die
sachsen besiegen und unterwerfen
schon sein vater und sein großvater
haben das fränkische reich durch
eroberungen ständig vergrößert aber hier
auf dem heiligen platz der in suhl
geht es um mehr
carmel die fremde kultur aus löschen ein
wo er herrscht soll nur ein glaube sein
seine gott
ist mit dem franken sie sollen es mit
eigenen augen sie reißt das götzen bild
um
was geschieht mit einem volk dessen
religiöse gefühle derart verletzt werden
es sind schläge die das ganze
sächsischer gebiet in aufruhr versetzen
alle darf an der weser und der elbe
zwischen thüringen und der nordsee ein
flächenbrand
die sächsischen priester sind überzeugt
dass die götter diesen ungeheuren frevel
verhindern
denn wenn diese säule feld stürzte
himmel herab
doch die sächsischen götter schweigen
[Musik]
das ist
der widerstand der sachse ist noch nicht
gebrochen wie du kind ruft zum kampf
gegen die fränkischen besatzer auf
erreicht das schwert
[Musik]
unsere vorväter
widersetzt euch denken an die demütigung
durch die franken macht view kind zum
rebellen zum anführer der sachsen der
sich berufen fühlt der fränkischen
supermacht zu trotzen
im namen der eigenen göttern
märz
für eure freiheit
oder ist mit uns wir werden siegen
brüder highlight
roland
[Applaus]
das reich des jungen königs karl ist
riesig sein großvater kern mattel und
sein vater könig pippin haben es in
ständigen kriegen erinnerung vergrößert
es erstreckt sich von thüringen bis in
die provence und vom mittelmeer bis zum
atlantik
senden ii bei paris ist im achten
jahrhundert eine wichtige residenz
dieses reiches
[Musik]
kam entstand keiner alteingesessenen
herrscher familie seine vorfahren haben
es aber geschafft das fränkische
königsgeschlecht der merowinger
auszuschalten und sich selbst zu
herrschern zu machen
karl martell der großvater begründet
eine mächtige dynastie in der auch der
papst ein bündnis schließen will
18 jahre vor dem überfall auf die
sachsen hat der junge karl kaum sechs
jahre alt eine begegnungen die zum
schlüsselerlebnis wird papst stefan der
zweite kommt aus rom um mit karls vater
dem fränkischen könig pippin eine
allianz zu schließen der pontifex
braucht dringend eine schutzmacht um
seine stellung in italien zu behaupten
und die franken suchen die anerkennung
ihres königtums durch den papst der
kleine karl begrüßt ihn feierlich
[Musik]
ich danke dir dein vater kann sehr stolz
auf dich sein
könig pippin was der sechsjährige junge
jetzt noch nicht begreifen kann wird
sein ganzes leben bestimmen das bündnis
seiner familie mit dem papst da ist der
kleine karl leisten durfte hat ihn
sicherlich in der hinsicht beeinflusst
dass er erfüllt war von der idee die
gebote gottes die gesetze gottes zu
verbreiten und auch dazu vorbereitet die
heiden kriege die kriege gegen die
sachsen zu führen missions- kriege und
eroberungskriege
eroberung und missionierung das schwert
und das kreuz mit der waffe wird der
glaube durchgesetzt erst das schwert
macht einen jungen franken zum mann und
krieger wenn er von adel ist stammt
seine klingen meist von ulf berg aus der
berühmtesten waffenschmiede derzeit das
logo steht für eine hightech klinge
bessere schwerte gibt es nirgends
[Musik]
ungefähr 400 dieser klingen hat man
gefunden zumeist den gräbern bedeutender
männer einem krieger wurden seine waffen
mit ins jenseits gegeben obwohl sie ein
vermögen gekostet haben
axt sperrschild
und das schwert
es sind die waffen der fränkischen
kämpfer
[Musik]
im alter von 15 jahren hat karl seiner
ausbildung zum krieger abgeschlossen
in einer feierlichen zeremonie
wiederholt den er schon als kleiner
junge abgelegt hat ich glaube meine
königliche macht stets zum schutz der
christenheit einzusetzen und zur
verbreitung der göttlichen wahrheit als
nunmehr erwachsener mann erhält er sein
eigenes schwert
nimm das schwert es wird dich dein leben
lang begleiten sowohl im krieg als auch
im frieden
[Musik]
die halten sollen dieses werden
wie die sachsen so verehren im achten
jahrhundert auch die anderen heidnischen
völker im osten ihre eigenen götter die
abo treten sorgen und die böhmen
sie alle sehen das göttliche in den
erscheinungen der natur
[Musik]
für die sachsen sind die externsteinen
gelegen beim heutigen detmold ein
kultischer ort egal ist überzeugt die
sächsischen heiden schon endgültig
bezwungen zu haben
ein erster schritt ihr land auf dauer
einzuverleiben
in einem akt der unterwerfung sollen die
sachsen seine herrschaft anerkennen mein
team die treue schön bekennt jetzt ihr
männer aus dem folgt der sachsen
wollt ihr euch den mächtigen
christlichen könig der franken
unterwerfen für alle zeit
es ist eine mit gewalt erzwungen treue
was bleibt den besiegten
es gibt nur unterwerfung oder tod
[Musik]
entweder man verrät seine eigene kultur
oder man verliert das leben
[Musik]
damit sei frieden nun zwischen euch und
uns karl glaubt damit sei sachsen
besiegt
täuscht er sich
[Musik]
der stamm der sachsen stellt keine
geschlossene einheit da es gibt eine
ganze reihe von teil stemmen die
westfalen die eng an die ost verein sind
die berühmtesten so dass sie auch
militärisch nicht unter einem befehl
stehen uns diese kriege werden von
diesen verschiedenen stämmen geführt so
dass ein sieg des großen keineswegs dazu
führt dass der gesamte sachsen stammt
nun endgültig besiegt wäre
ein jahr nach dem krieg gegen die
sachsen sieht karl mit seinem ehe über
die alpen um das langobarden königreich
zu erobern
kabel die alte römische provinz italia
an seinem fränkischen reich einverleiben
obwohl die langobarden christen sind
viele monate lang belagerten er ihre
hauptstadt pavia er hungert die
bevölkerung aus bis sie kapituliert
alles für einen großen traum seine
vision
dann stünde er in augenhöhe mit dem
oströmischen kaiser in konstantinopel
das untergegangene weströmische reich
soll wieder erstehen
der unvergleichliche glanz des alten rom
soll sich mit seinem frankenreich
verbindungen ein imperium ein glaube
ein herrscher
[Musik]
im jahre 774 wird karl der rex frankfurt
langobarden der könig der franken und
der langobarden
[Musik]
in der schatzkammer der kathedrale von
monza wird bis heute die alte
langobarden königskrone aufbewahrt
mehr als 1000 jahre lang bis ins 19
jahrhundert oder sie von vielen
nachfolgern karls des großen getragen
man nennt sie die eiserne krone
doch sie ist das purem gold und mir 22
kostbaren edelsteinen besetzt von ihnen
verstärkt sie ein eiserner ring daher
der name
[Musik]
in dem jungen und oft so grausamen
krieger könig karl der nur mühsam lesen
und schreiben kann scheint noch ein
anderer zu stecken
ein mann der sich nach wissen und
bildung sind und nach der schönheit der
künste
karl der große hat wie jeder fränkische
adelige 1 training zum krieger erhalten
natürlich keine schulausbildung in
unserem sinne
aber karl hatte weil er dieses reich
regieren wollte weil er fasziniert war
von der mittelmeer welt und der antiken
kultur sehr schnell die idee entwickelt
an seinem hof spezialisten zu versammeln
denen er diese aufgabe der
bildungsreform übertrug diese
spezialisten sind mönche und kleriker
sie kommen aus irland england spanien
und italien
es sind große gelehrte die besten köpfe
ihrer zeit
karl will ihnen zuhören will von ihnen
lernen das heilige fundament seines
königtums soll die heilige schrift die
bibel sein
auch bei ganz alltäglichen fragen denn
steht nicht geschrieben in der heiligen
schrift dass auch gott der herr selbst
am siebten tage rote und gott segnete
den siebten tag und heiligte ihn weil
armut von all seinen werken die gott
geschaffen und gemacht ihr wollt also
der sonntag soll frei sein von arbeiten
es wäre gottgefällig nach seinem wild
alle christen menschen sollen diesen tag
dem herrn widmen
unter familie
so seien
krieg und unterdrückung gelehrsamkeit
und schönheit für karl ist das kein
widerspruch
was karl und seine hof gelehrten
beginnen ist nicht nur eine grundlegende
bildungsreform
es ist beinahe die wiedergeburt der
klassischen lateinischen welt seit dem
untergang roms und dem chaos der
völkerwanderung war diese antike kultur
verkümmert
das warten der mönche und priester war
verbindet ihre schrift kaum zu lesen
karl spürt eine sprache eine schrift
sind für die formung seines reiches
unabdingbar
seht ihr beim schreiben muss es eine
klare ordnung gehen klare regeln einer
muss schreiben wieder andere damit es
jeder lesen kann
[Musik]
das müssen alle lernen auch ihr
das schreiben und das abschreiben ein
strenges handwerk das vor allem mönche
in klöstern betreiben das ganze wissen
der welt soll festgehalten werden
die schrift die wir heute noch schreiben
geht's auf diese bildungsreform zurück
auf die chronische - kühl mit
worttrennung klar lesbare buchstaben
eine schrift die dazu geführt hat dass
man die wichtigen antiken texte und
kirchlichen texte im ganzen frankenreich
verbreiten und lesen konnte
[Musik]
überall in seinem reich fördert karl die
gründung von klöstern von dateien
schulen und bibliotheken
und bis heute findet man an vielen orten
europas kostbare sammlung von
handschriften aus der zeit karls des
großen
so auch im benediktinerkloster melk in
niederösterreich
es sind großartige zeugnisse jener
gelehrsamkeit die man die karolingische
renaissance nimmt
es ist ein aufbruch fast in allen
bereichen des wissens und des lebens der
sich auch in den karolingischen bauten
spiegelt in der über 1000 jahre alten
torhalle des klosters lorsch in
südhessen
[Musik]
die andere seite seiner macht im
sachsenland herrschen immer noch krieg
und aufruhr unterdrückung und gewalt
dann hat ein gesetz erlassen das jeden
mit dem tode bedroht der sich der taufe
entzieht
[Musik]
wie das sagst du den teufel und all
seinen werken acquis akropolis berkum
antwort juni wurden ende sachs note ende
allem dem unhold wenn du dich wahrhaftig
bekehren willst zum gott der christen
zur wird nun als zeichen deines neuen
glaubens deine götzen bilder in dieses
reinigende feuer im namen des vaters des
sohnes des heiligen geistes kamen die
sachsen sollen ihrem alten glauben
abschwören
sie sollen aufhören die zu sein die sie
sind
menschen die über generationen trainiert
waren sich in dieser viel götterwelt zu
bewegen und sie als die natürliche
ordnung zu erachten wenn sich immer sehr
schwer tun unter militärischem druck und
unter gewaltandrohung plötzlich dem
vertrauten abzuschwören
die sachsen haben das machen müssen in
der ersten phase der fränkischen
expansion und sie haben es einfach
gemacht weil sie keine alternative
hatten aber sie sind dadurch keine
gläubigen christen geworden wie du kennt
und seine krieger wollen sich nicht
taufen lassen
trotz der todesdrohung an rohm haas lebe
oder pdfs die sachsen lb sandy udo
kienle
dort in der musik video das ensi wandern
[Musik]
wieso kennt will dass die sachsen wieder
herren im eigenen land sind und dass sie
ihre eigenen götter anbieten dürfen und
nicht diesen fremden gott mit feuer und
schwert kam
aber wie
wie
die sachsen schlagen zurück angriff auf
fränkische dörfern
aber
[Musik]
keine gnade für die feinde auch nicht
für jene sachsen die schon christen sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie dawkins kampf fordert unschuldige
opfer eines
gerade der gewalt
ich hatte gehofft so etwas niemals hören
zu müssen diese verfluchten heiden
diese verdammten sachsen heutige hunde
treulose park wir wollten sie mit dem
schwert unterwerfen aber ihre herzen zu
gewinnen haben wir zusammen die uns nur
gebrochen
sie haben nicht warten ihren könig aber
unser gott ist doch ein gott der liebe
ein reich ein glaube das müssen wir
durchsetzen
nirgendwo steht geschrieben dass gottes
wort mit dem schwert allein verbreitet
werden muss jesus gestrickt
[Musik]
ich schwöre vor gott und vor euch
das treulose und wortbrüche folgte
sachsen mit krieg zu überziehen
und nicht mehr zur ruhe bis es entweder
besiegt und zu christlichen religion
gekehrt ist oder aber wenn die sachsen
ist nicht anders wollen dass sie
vollständig von der erde verlegt werden
es ist ein kampf der keine regeln kennt
und keine rücksicht
ein schmutziger krieg zwischen
ungleichen rechten den überfällen
strafaktion terror und gegen terror
und nur selten stellen sich die rebellen
zur offenen schlag
und nie ist wie du kind zu fassen
wie du kind
[Musik]
wo ist er
so ist der täter wo bist du wie du kennt
[Musik]
in verden an der aller wird karl ein
exempel statuieren
es ist eine rache orgie
nie wieder soll ein sachse es wagen sich
gegen die nie zu erheben
den könig der franken
auf gasbefehle werden wohl über 1000
gefangenen sachsen hingerichtet
fränkische chronisten behaupten später
sogar man habe an diesem einen tag 4500
männer mit dem schwert getötet
[Musik]
das wasser der aller habe sich rot
gefärbt vom blut der opfer
[Musik]
eine tat die über die jahrhunderte einen
schatten auf das bild des großen
frankenkönigs wirft
bei verden an der aller erinnern 4500
steine an das geschehen gesetzt im jahr
1935 im geist der zeit
das blutbad von werden hat bereits bei
zeitgenossen eine gewisse kritik
hervorgerufen
auch die über große brutalität mit der
karl der große vorgegangen ist
auf der anderen seite wenn man sich in
karls situation versetzt so hat man doch
auch den eindruck dass er ein stück weit
verzweifelt gewesen ist ob dieses lang
anhaltenden widerstands von seiten der
sachsen und das sozusagen es sein
letztes mittel gewesen ist um den erfolg
zu erzwingen
der ungeheure zorn des frankenkönigs
macht auch vor frauen und kindern nicht
halt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seine eigenen hof schreiber berichten
paulis alle sachsen die jenseits der
elbe wohnten mit frauen und kindern ins
frankenland schaffen
hier ist darauf ja immer in bewegung
es ist eine zwangsumsiedlung um die
eigene herrschaft zu sichern
[Musik]
zehntausende sachsen werden ihre heimat
beraubt und ins fränkische kern land
deportiert
[Musik]
das land das ihnen genommen wird
verteilt kann an seiner fränkischen
gefolgsleute
[Musik]
trotz aller grausamkeiten ist der
widerstand der sachsen nicht zu brechen
beide seiten sind gefangene ihres
stolzes ihre ziele ihre spüren
die sachsen haben nicht die kraft die
fränkische großmacht aus dem land zu
vertreiben
worauf er wie dawkins gegner gibt es
eine bittere erkenntnis allein mit
militärischer gewalt kann es keinen
dauerhaften frieden geben
davon wollen karls gelehrte berater
ihren könig schließlich überzeugen
seit 13 jahren führen wir nun krieg
gegen die sachsen ein
sie führen krieg gegen uns und wir haben
ihren widerstand nicht brechen können
trotz aller anstrengungen ich sage euch
wir finden keinen frieden mit den
sachsen wenn wir nicht verhandeln
verhandeln ich dann sagt mir wie die
verhandelt man mit brüchigen aufhören
die sich an keine spur gebunden fühlt
und keine gesetze achten wie wir bieten
wie du kind eine ehrenvolle kapitulation
an bei der er sein gesicht wahren kann
so kann er einem krieg bis zum letzten
mann entgehen aber dafür muss er den
aufstand beenden ein für allemal
er muss sich taufen lassen
[Musik]
um des friedens wie gut die pax christi
an
es wäre ein gottgefälliges werk
galler große hat in sachsen pflege
unendlich viel investiert und das
deutete er schon an wie sehr ihm daran
gelegen war seine mission die zum ersten
mal auf leuchtet bei dem der papst
stefan geleistet hat seine mission zu
ende zu führen
13 jahre nach der zerstörung der insulin
der sächsische rebellenführer ins
frankenland zukam
die fränkischen chronisten werden später
behaupten der sachse sei durch ein
göttliches wunder zum gläubigen christen
geworden
in wahrheit wie video kind einfach nur
frieden wie du kommst du aus freien
stücken jahren könig des friedens willen
als karl am weihnachtstag des jahres 785
den früheren todfeind in die arme
schließt erfüllt er das versprechen dass
er schon als kleiner junge dem papst
gegeben hat
das christentum zu verbreiten
die taufe wie dawkins ist ein
bedeutendes ereignis in der
vorgeschichte der deutschen das land der
sachsen wird teil eines reiches aus dem
später deutschland ebenso wie frankreich
hervorgehen wird
die laube stewing gottvater artikel ab
glaubst du in christ gottes synergien
tonnen ich glaube du bist du in hailer
geist
[Musik]
so darf ich dich wie du kind vom volk
der sachsen
im namen des vaters
[Musik]
und des sohnes
und des heiligen geistes
ab
[Musik]
die taufe video 4 785 war für karl ein
ungeheurer erfolg seine chronisten haben
notiert ganz sachsen ist jetzt unter
waffen
in wirklichkeit braucht es noch einmal
20 jahre oder fast 20 jahre bis es
soweit war
trotzdem war man sich sicher dass man
jetzt ein christliches reich unter einem
christlichen könig und mit lauter
christen gerichtet hätte die ältesten
teile der stiftskirche von pinger einem
dorf bei herford stammen aus der zeit um
804 wurde wieder kind geboren und hier
soll er der legende nach auch begraben
sein
die chronisten haben den rebellen zu
einem frommen mann umgedeutet
ein späterer papst sprach ihn selig
das national bewusste neunzehnte
jahrhundert hat in sachsen video kind zu
einem deutschen volkshelden im kampf
gegen die feindlichen franzosen
stilisiert und umgekehrt haben die
franzosen aus karl den großen einen der
ihren gemacht charlemagne ist demnach
franzose vor dem video kind der deutsche
im staub kniet
geschichtsklitterung von beiden seiten
in einer zeit der sogenannten
erbfeindschaft
[Musik]
nach der taufe des sächsischen rebellen
kann sich kann endlich seinen anderen
projekten widmen
der monarch verfügt zwar über eine reihe
prächtiger residenzen aber das riesige
reich hat noch immer keinen festen
regierungssitz
[Musik]
kann welt machen um es zur schönsten
stadt seines landes zu machen
aachen soll die pacht von rom und die
gelehrsamkeit athens in sich vereint
[Musik]
die neue königspfalz ist eine große und
perfekt geplante anlage
zu ihr gehört die aula regia als
regierungssitz außerdem ein wohnhaus für
die königliche familie ein garnison
gebäude für elitetruppen ein
gerichtssaal und ein studienzentrum mit
archiv und bibliotheken
das geistliche zentrum ist die
pfalzkapelle die der jungfrau maria
geweiht ist leute der aachener dom
er gilt schon bei den zeitgenossen karls
als wunderwerk
damals der prächtigste kirchenbau
diesseits der alpen
[Musik]
das innere der kirche jahrhundertelang
war es der höchste kuppel überwölbte
raum in nordeuropa
marmor aus carrara und säulen aus rom
und ravenna
33 deutsche könige haben sie später auf
karel berufen
und diesen thron im aachener dom
bestiegen
im laufe von 600 jahren
ach war die bevorzugte pfalz kreises
großen das macht sicherlich daran dass
der ortsmitten im kerngebiet der
karolingischen herrschaft lag darum
herum gab es ausgedehnte wälder
hervorragend geeignet für die jagd und
dann gab es dort die warmen quellen in
denen sich keiner große jedes jahr holte
im jahre 800 sie karl mit großem gefolge
nach syrien
er hat mit dem papst eine ganz besondere
verabredung getroffen
rom
ehemals zentrum der antiken welt zu
karls zeiten seine bedeutung schon lange
verloren
[Musik]
doch selbst die ruinen zeugen von
früherer größer
[Musik]
seit mehr als drei jahrhunderten hat es
in westeuropa keinen kaiser mehr geben
[Musik]
im jahre 800 greift der fränkische könig
karl nach dem alten titel temperaturen
will die renovation peri die erneuerung
des römischen reiches als reich der
franken
[Musik]
die kaiserkrönung am weihnachtstag des
jahres 800 ist ein historischer moment
schon für die zeitgenossen
es ist eine sensation die ganz europa
bewegt zum ersten mal krönt ein papst
einen kaiser
zum ersten mal stampft dieser kaiser aus
einem anderen reich als dem römisch
nur der stellvertreter petry kann den
kaisertitel in göttlichem auftrag
verleihen
deshalb muss karl den kirchenfürsten als
sein geistliches oberhaupt anerkennen
umgekehrt hat erst karl das papsttum von
der pizza athenischen vorherrschaft
befreit und unter seinen militärischen
schutz gestellt
deshalb muss der papst dem neuen kaiser
als seinen weltlichen herrscher huldigen
fast ein halbes jahrhundert nach dem
besuch des papstes ins anthony hat sich
die politische vision der karolinger
erfüllt eine dauerhafte koalition der
weltlichen mit der geistlichen macht
eine verbindung von schwert und kreuz
[Musik]
der weg dahin war lang er war
rücksichtslos und grausam benachbarte
völker wurden niedergeworfen
andersgläubige menschen mit gewalt zum
christentum bekehrt
die krönung karls im jahr 800 begründet
dass künftige mittelalterliche kaisertum
das in der form des heiligen römischen
reiches über 1000 jahre lang bestehen
wird
jahrhundertelang werden es deutsche
könige sein die sich in rom zum kaiser
krönen lassen
in der tradition des großen carolinas
deshalb spricht man später vom heiligen
römischen reich deutscher nation dessen
letzter kaiser bis 1806 regieren wird
und selbst apulien der diese römisch
deutsche tradition beendet erhebt sich
in der kathedrale notre dame in paris
zum nachfolger von karl dem großen
die bedeutung des großen für uns heute
liegt waren dass er symbolhaft
beispielhaft die verschiedenen völker
und traditionen großer teile europas
zusammen gebunden hat zusammengefasst
hat und dass er diese verbindung unter
die leitidee eines friedens raumes eine
einheit des friedens stellt auch wenn er
ständig kriege geführt hat letztlich
sollte ein friedensreich entstehen karl
stimmt im jahre 814
und wird in seiner kirche begraben er
war franke und der erste europäer
anderthalb jahrhunderte nach karl wird
sich ein mann aus dem unterworfenen
folgt der sachsen otto der erste in
aachen zum könig krönen lassen
in der schlacht auf dem lechfeld besiegt
der sachse im jahr 955 die heidnischen
mclaren
im kampf gegen den äußeren feind und er
die stimme des ostfränkischen reiches
[Musik]
und so beginnt eine neue geschichte
die der deutschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]